[Musica]
viviamo in un'epoca di profondi
cambiamenti
ce ne rendiamo conto tutti i giorni da
ormai tanti anni
quando parlo di cambiamenti non intendo
strettamente quello che è successo negli
ultimi due anni ma intendo quello che
succede da ormai più di 15 anni quella
che viene cambiata rivoluzione
tecnologica il cambiamento tecnologico
la tecnologia una parola che deriva
dalla tecnica e la tecnica è un elemento
che dà dal 1600 da dalla nascita della
scienza e dal metodo scientifico
tecnicamente appunto viene
associata storicamente a
soggetti che gestiscono le masse non dal
basso la tecnologia è una prerogativa di
corporazioni governi strutture
importanti
la tecnologia come intendiamo oggi è il
cambiamento invece di cui siamo
partecipi oggi ha una caratteristica
diversa e questa caratteristica la
possiamo associare a due parole
l'accessibilità e lo scambio
quando parlo di accessibilità è una
caratteristica specifica della
tecnologia del cambiamento che stiamo
vivendo oggi
poter sviluppare tecnologia poter
cambiare il mondo il proprio mondo con
applicazioni o con servizi tecnologici
non è più appannaggio di grosse
corporazioni non è più appannaggio di
governi ma è una cosa disponibile a
tutti
è ovviamente necessario
saperlo fare
ed è il motivo per cui negli ultimi anni
appunto circa negli ultimi 15 20 anni ma
forse in alcune aree geografiche da
ancora di più abbiamo un fiorire di
nuove competenze di nuovi soggetti che
gestiscono e che hanno competenze
tecnologiche questi soggetti non sono
esperti con decine di anni di esperienza
ma sono molto spesso ragazzi sono molto
spesso ragazzi che sviluppano start up
sviluppano progetti innovativi
partendo da un'idea e dalla possibilità
che hanno appunto di accedere a
tecnologia la seconda parola che
ho citato e scambio la tecnologia
moderna e il mondo in cui viviamo si
caratterizza anche per lo scambio lo
scambio che permette di condividere
permette di una crescita reciproca
dell'heavy di emozioni di progetti di
economia
e quindi lo scambio diventa un elemento
appunto che è il filo conduttore
conduttore fra la te lo sviluppo di
tecnologia e lo sviluppo del pianeta in
tutti i suoi in tutte le sue componenti
in questa immagine ho messo un neonato è
un codice
qual è la connessione per queste due
immagini la connessione è legata al
linguaggio perché la tecnologia e lo
scambio
poi hanno necessità di linguaggi per
poter essere gestite per poter essere
manipolate
l'uomo da sempre risponde alle sue
necessità di manipolazione della natura
attraverso il linguaggio e alla tecnica
e che quindi nel mondo moderno
linguaggio e tecnica si fondono insieme
e ci portano in una nuova era della
comunicazione e dello sviluppo anche
economico del nostro paese e del nostro
mondo dove l'accessibilità appunto il
cambiamento è aperta non è più chiusa
come in passato
questo ovviamente ha delle conseguenze
ha delle conseguenze molto importanti
come ad esempio il fatto di rendere
obsoleto tutto quello che solo 30 anni
fa sembrava non dover cambiare mai la
televisione è un esempio perfetto perché
la televisione che era un media che
dominava il pensiero e la gestione delle
delle masse oggi ha un'importanza molto
relativa e il cambiamento è avvenuto in
pochissimi anni
questo
cosa significa significa che il periodo
che stiamo vivendo
avrà ripercussioni molto importanti sul
futuro e il futuro che ci apprestiamo a
vivere sarà completamente diverso dal
passato come come spesso è ma in
particolare in questo momento sarà un
cambiamento che io definisco epocale
la digitalizzazione l'avvento di
dispositivi tecnologici mobile gli
smartphone ovviamente ha accelerato
questo processo è un processo che era
già iniziati era già iniziato molto
prima ma questo questa innovazione ha
accelerato enormemente il processo e
soprattutto come dicevo prima adatto
ancora più velocità ha accesso e scambio
perché perché chiunque di noi addosso
tutto il giorno un dispositivo che gli
permette di scambiare informazioni
prodotti qualsiasi cosa con gli altri e
ad accesso alle informazioni alla
conoscenza a una serie di informazioni
attività che prima invece erano
ovviamente molto più complicate da
d'aver
e poi veniamo agli ultimi anni gli
ultimi due anni il covip dal mio punto
di vista
fa parte di questo cambiamento potremmo
dire che è l'apice di questo cambiamento
è il punto di rottura rispetto a quello
che in passato era già iniziato quindi
un cambiamento che era appunto già
iniziato ma il kovida accelerato
accelerato enormemente a livello globale
questo questo cambiamento
io lavoro nel settore della finanza
digitale e delle startup ormai da tanti
anni e quello che si è notato
sicuramente in modo evidente negli
ultimi due anni è come abbiamo fatto un
salto di 10 anni in avanti nell'arco
appunto di un anno e mezzo due anni
questo ad esempio alcuni settori è stato
un cambiamento epocale il settore
finanziario sta avendo dei cambiamenti
diciamo che non avranno più un ritorno
indietro gli acquisti l'avvento dell'e
commerce in modo importante in italia
c'è stato un incremento a doppia cifra
del dell'utilizzo delle piattaforme di e
commerce in modo inaspettato veloce e su
argomenti e su prodotti che prima invece
erano completamente snobbati come
all'alimentari ad esempio
in più
ancora a spingere in modo ancora più
importante questo cambiamento
c'è il piano economico europeo di
incentivazione il famoso recovery fund
che dal mio punto di vista avrà un ruolo
cruciale nel cambiamento tecnologico e
nell'accelerazione tecnologica del
nostro del nostro nel nostro continente
ma del nostro mondo
sì perché il recovery fund non europeo
il recovery fund c'è in europa e negli
stati uniti c'è in asia c'è in africa è
un momento globale di concentrazione di
risorse economiche e di energie per
rispondere a un'esigenza di cambiamento
e quindi questa importante massa di
liquidità di soldi che arrivano
sull'innovazione proprio in questo
momento storico all'apice di un lungo
cambiamento
accelereranno in modo inevitabile è
veramente importante
il mondo che andremo a conoscere
i farmaci ad esempio lo sviluppo delle
farmacie on line lo sviluppo di
biotecnologie nuove
l'avvento dell'online gaming a livelli
mai visti prima
la finanza digitale sono solo alcuni
degli esempi che potrà portarvi per
raccontare quanto questi elementi stanno
cambiando il nostro mondo
quando parlavo di scambio e dentro una
parte diciamo più economiche dello
scambio ovviamente si parla anche di
scambio elettronico legato a l'economia
alla finanza
quando parliamo di scambio si viene
subito in mente il pagamento come
diciamo momento di scambio di beni e
servizi ed è corretto il pagamento è un
elemento centrale storicamente da
dall'inizio dell'economia lo scambio è
sinonimo di pagamento che sia baratto
che sia fondato su soldi o
quant'altro e di conseguenza questo
elemento sta cambiando in modo
importante e molto velocemente oggi
molti di noi sono abituati a pagare con
smartphone
ovviamente con le carte con altri
sistemi con il cellulare con appunto
anche l'orologio in alcuni casi e questo
ovviamente non fa altro che accelerare
lo scambio economico che appunto è alla
base dell'economia quindi aumenta
l'accessibilità ad esempio al credito
alla possibilità di dilazionare un
acquisto a poter comprare online
però questo ovviamente anche delle
conseguenze negative
cioè negative diciamo a delle
conseguenze poi ognuno di noi deciderà
se sono negative o positive e lo vedremo
nel futuro
il questa interconnessione questo
accesso alla comunicazione alla
tecnologia
sta creando soprattutto nei paesi
occidentali una nuova categoria di
individui individui che proprio grazie
anche alle sovvenzioni che vengono da
questo nuova economia questo nuovo
modello diciamo di sviluppo
derivante dal fatto anche che le
competenze che servono a rimanere sul
mercato oggi sono sempre più difficili
da avere e di conseguenza abbiamo una
fetta importante della popolazione che è
fuori da questa da queste competenze e
ha necessità di sostentamento e di
sovvenzioni giustamente e ovviamente i
governi agiscono e sovvenzionano questa
fetta della popolazione che è sempre più
grande ma questo crea appunto una fascia
di popolazione che ad oggi non cerca
lavoro non lavora ovviamente non ha una
forma di sostentamento molto spesso
appunto sussidiaria e non non a quello
spirito con l'impulso necessario a
riattivare l'economia dei paesi
tipicamente occidentali
questo unito all'interconnessione che
oggi appunto è molto accessibile molto
economica non non serve
chissà quale
stipendio per poter avere uno smartphone
un computer o internet da questo questa
possibilità di diciamo soddisfazione
anche a questa fascia della popolazione
che la frena ancor di più verso il
mercato dell'economia il mercato del
lavoro e questo ovviamente crea delle
conseguenze
un'altra delle conseguenze è legata
appunto a il cashless l'abbandono del
caro vecchio contante quello che per
secoli ha dominato la nostra economia è
oggi tecnicamente va verso l'estinzione
superato da altre tecnologie
il contante alla fine non è altro che un
mezzo uno strumento fisico in olanda
siamo a un passo dalla cashless completo
dalla possibilità di abbandonare
completamente il denaro contante in
favore di sistemi di pagamento
elettronico e questo ovviamente anche in
questo caso il cambierà profondamente il
nostro rapporto con l'economia
ma adesso passiamo da da diciamo
lo zoom che abbiamo fatto sul occidente
su questi aspetti di cambiamento
mettiamo grandangolo guardiamo un attimo
cosa sta succedendo intorno a noi nel
mondo
ecco questa evoluzione tecnologica di
cui abbiamo parlato nei paesi emergenti
in particolare in africa ma anche nel
sud est asiatico e in atto da molto
prima e in atto da molto prima e sotto
l'aspetto economico ha una
caratteristica questi paesi infatti
hanno un
bancarizzazione molto bassa e di
conseguenza hanno saltato tutta quella
parte di sviluppo economico che riguarda
le banche tradizionali e sono arrivati
sono già arrivati da anni a lo sviluppo
delle tecnologie di pagamento e di
finanza mobile perché perché sono paesi
dove appunto quasi nessuno ha un conto
corrente
ma a parte le aziende chiaramente ma
tutti hanno uno smartphone e vogliono
avere accesso a servizi finanziari e
quindi stiamo assistendo in questi paesi
a una domanda di servizi finanziari
senza precedenti nella storia è
veramente importante proprio perché c'è
tutta la popolazione che ne ha bisogno
non è come in occidente dove abbiamo
solo una parte della popolazione che ne
ha bisogno perché perché la maggior
parte e bancarizzata non ha necessità di
questi strumenti mentre in questi paesi
tutti hanno necessità di questi
strumenti proprio perché non sono
bancarizzati e vogliono avere accesso
alle all'economia c'è una piccola
storiella che vi cito velocemente che
parla di come in etiopia ad esempio si è
passati da comprare coi propri risparmi
bestiame a gestire cripto valuta non c'è
stato il passaggio in mezzo non c'è
stata la parte di contante non c'è stata
la parte c'era da parte del contante ma
ci vogliono diciamo delle borse molto
capienti perché la valuta è molto
svalutata e quindi è molto difficile
gestire l'economia tradizionale e loro
stanno passando velocemente da la
gestione del risparmio acquistando
bestiame perché perché quando hai del
risparmio compri qualcosa che puoi
vedere che puoi gestire che poi appunto
come contante e stanno passando
direttamente al mobile e alla finanza
decentralizzata senza passare da tutto
il mondo tradizionale
e quindi appunto questo crea tutta una
serie di nuove concezioni di nuove
possibilità di nuove modalità di accesso
al credito di immaginarsi l'economia di
questi paesi lo scambio anche di beni e
servizi verso l'esterno e verso
l'interno perché ovviamente questo crea
una serie di problematiche di gestione
di questa nuova economia emergente
qui vediamo come normalmente nei grafici
quando si confrontano i continenti e
quello piccolo è l'africa in realtà qui
quello grande l'africa che lo piccolo e
l'europa e questo è
l'utilizzo di mobile money cioè di
strumenti di pagamenti mobile per da
cellulare finanziario verità differenza
enorme fra i paesi africa africa e sud
est asiatico rispetto al resto del mondo
e l'accelerazione di questi anni e dieci
volte
l'accelerazione che abbiamo
europa e in occidente questo creerà nei
prossimi anni una rivoluzione enorme
perché tecnologicamente loro saranno
molto più avanti di noi saranno molto
più abituati di noi si creerà si sta
creando un'economia molto più adatta a
gestire il cambiamento rispetto alla
nostra
e questo e grafico finale perché il
cambiamento di cui ho parlato che
riguarda tutto l'aspetto economico e
comunicativo e tecnologico poi si
scontra con un altro cambiamento
importante quello demografico
la linea più alta e l'asia che oggi la
zona più popolosa ma è in stallo
addirittura calerà nei prossimi decenni
la linea che vedete invece salire in
modo vertiginose l'africa che avrà una
popolazione molto molto molto più ampia
e arriverà a superare quella asiatica in
futuro e tutte le altre sono tutti i
paesi occidentali
accorpati
questo ovviamente ci fa capire come
l'aspetto del cambiamento finanziario
tecnologico ed economico si unisce anche
un cambiamento demografico e di
conseguenza per chiudere
dobbiamo prepararci perché ovviamente
essere consapevoli del cambiamento è
l'unico modo per poter gestire grazie a
tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]